SPEAKER: SQL has many built-in
functions for performing
calculations on data.
But sometimes,
your systems might
need to handle data, such
as string or date values,
in a unique way.
User-defined functions
are an efficient way
to have these custom
calculations at your fingertips
when analyzing data.
On today's episode of
BigQuery spotlight,
we're talking about how to
create, store, and share
user-defined
functions in BigQuery.
So stick around.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So what is a User-Defined
Function, or UDF?
A UDF lets you create a reusable
function which you define,
with either another SQL
expression or with JavaScript.
These functions accept
input, perform actions,
and then return a
value as a result.
Once you've created a UDF, you
can reference it in queries
or when creating logical
views, just as you
would with built-in functions.
Let's see an example use case.
Imagine an application
that captures data
from various sources
and requires any text
fields to be cleansed
before they can be
used for analytical purposes.
We can write one UDF--
we'll call it cleanse_string--
to tackle this data cleansing
problem.
The SQL expression that defines
the UDF does three things.
It trims white spaces,
converts text to lowercase,
and removes symbols.
After creating and
defining the UDF,
in the next part of
the query statement,
we can test three
different strings of text
through our new function.
If we run the entire query.
We will see the before
and after results
for each string of text.
Once we are happy with the
function's performance,
we could add it to the query
statements that analyze data
from our application.
This example includes what
we call a temporary UDF,
meaning it is created
and used within one
single query statement.
However, BigQuery also
supports persistent UDFs,
which are defined and stored
within a specific project
and data set, but can be
reused across multiple queries
and projects.
Let's head into the console
and see how to create, use,
and share a persistent UDF.
You can follow along in
your own BigQuery sandbox.
If you don't have
one yet, set one up
following the video link below.
It's good to note
that in the sandbox,
your persistent UDFs
will remain indefinitely.
So they aren't limited to
the same 60-day storage limit
that tables have
within the sandbox.
Start in the Query Editor.
Here you'll define
your UDF using SQL,
following a specific syntax.
CREATE OR REPLACE
FUNCTION indicates
that you would like to
create a persistent UDF.
This is followed by your
project ID and data set name
where you want the UDF to live.
Next is the name for
the function itself.
In this case, cleanse_string.
Following in parentheses
is a comma-separated list
of all input parameters
with their data types
that your UDF requires.
For cleanse_string, you
have just one input,
which is a string of text.
On the next line, the return
clause specifies the data type
that the function will return.
Now it's time to provide a
SQL expression that defines
how to process the input.
This expression uses
the SQL functions TRIM
to trim whitespace and LOWER to
convert the text to lowercase.
Then it uses a
regular expression
to remove any symbols.
Now you're ready to click Run
to create the persistent UDF.
You will see a populate under
your data set in the left hand
nav.
Selecting the UDF allows you
to view, edit, or delete it.
But first, let's use it.
We'll bring up the same
query that we showed earlier
in the video, but
this time we can
reference the persistent
UDF without needing
to provide its definition
within the same query statement.
Going forward, you
can use this UDF
just like you would any
other SQL function, directly
within your query statements.
You will need to reference
it with its full name,
including the project and
data set in which it resides.
In fact, any user with
the adequate permission
to the data set containing the
UDF, such as the BigQuery data
viewer role, can also
reference it in their queries.
By sharing data sets,
you have the potential
to create an org-wide library of
UDFs, which in turn can ensure
business logic is applied
consistently and efficiently
across your organization.
Now that you know how to create
and use UDFs in BigQuery,
it's time to start
writing some of your own.
If you're looking for
inspiration or perhaps
to just not reinvent the wheel,
check out the Resources link
below.
They include several
UDF examples, including
many written in JavaScript.
Thanks for joining us today
for BigQuery spotlight.
Watch out for the next episode.
And remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]